au premier coup d'oeil on pourrait
croire qu'il s'agit d'un jet-ski un peu
bricolé erreur c'est en fait un kite
surf à voile pour des skippers en
situation de handicap
le projet était présenté pour la
première fois par l'association de voile
de l'estaca l'objectif c'était que de
créer un support qui est adapté pour les
nationaux surtout pour les handicapés
mais du coup aussi pour les valides et
c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi cette forme
parce que en fait avec le lacet halle
centrale d'inde jet ski c'est assez
adapté pour les handicapés pour qu'il
soit stable
la forme trimaran aussi parce que ça te
permet une grande stabilité sur l'eau
elle la présentation de ce prototype
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la première
journée mobilité pour tous organisée par
l'école une première pour sensibiliser
les ingénieurs de demain sur la
problématique du handicap de faire
rencontrer les étudiants et les
professionnels sur la thématique de la
mobilité et de le et la situation
d'handicap dans la mobilité pour
c'est un métier d'avenir c'est un métier
où la population vieillit il faudra
prendre de plus en plus en compte ces
difficultés de mobilité au sein de la
conception également de la production
atelier découverte conférences ou encore
animations sportives et est notamment
programmé pour cette journée spéciale
une journée qui a convaincu les
principaux intéressés
ça permet de
du temps de casser ses idées reçues et
de casser cette gêne vis-à-vis du tpx
juste des gens tout à fait normaux qui
juste eu la malchance de se trouver dans
ces fauteuils au niveau des études et ça
fait partie des sujets qu'on n'aborde
pas spécialement parce que c'est qu'une
petite partie des employés mais du coup
ils sont quand même là et c'est
important de savoir tout ce qui est mis
en oeuvre pour les intégrer l
intégration professionnelle reste encore
une des problématiques principales pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
19 % d'entre eux sont au chômage
aujourd'hui c'est deux fois plus que la
moyenne nationale